it wasn't easy to track these down and i
got a shoe for you to rock you're a big
guy so i had to think about comfort so
these shoes are for you
they're the sake sakai and nike collab
you know the vaporizers because you
vaporize people and these these are hard
to find for a big guy you have a
japanese company that collabs and now i
haven't put red laces in them
so it actually represents the flag of
your your home country so they're comfy
you got rock sandals on now let's go
ahead and burn those and we can put
those on doug
so this is just for you man thank you
very much and when your knees better
those will be good to run in good with
jeans you're gonna fly flying back to
africa in those man they're dope
[Music]
super thick boy